maybe you have a
little less worries at the moment less helpless
nights than what in germany
simply because here you are
really decentralized using
the resources that we have here on
site and it is not tied to oil or gas from
russia or from the arabic world
this is the first and only
thrill eenergy software gmbh
that manages what many other places can
uni trier for this all the energy it
needs of the decade is it comes from the wind
sanacorp jb frau the veltheimers have
joined forces here to have their
own electricity and heating network  to
operate and that is unique in
germany
that means the 0 1 and almost
caught veltheim residenz dependent but
interested in power computer residential building
in germany home will nicole veltheim
energy marco hepp
included concept the web community
its goal is free last corner
lures
[music  ]
tears michael rapid man came up with the
idea of ​​making jubel ener  gy
becking handys i say to the predecessors salon
the vogelbauer bospop we were looking for
a place where there are
very good wind conditions inland
and we found it here in veltheim
capitulation of
the 4 you could show him
it looks like this it costs that
convinced him because the trust was there
and we talked to each other a
lot and managed
to find compromises through all the players.
now comes the company
with his veto
can influence with decisions
then the concern is also that
something happens what I would like
market one fears looking for
insurance building up finds at the
rapid menz I proudly knew from
veltheim energy mirco the fifth plant
that was built that was  a bourgeois
wind
turbine, i.e. a system that the citizens both here in front of
or  t but also from other places in the
surrounding area, customers today made
heart fifty five winds and
getting the dance and offered an
ebeling and invest in the party bye
weight watchers participation and
support the decision on how
to do it financially points out from an
economic point of view
it's up to the citizenry so
they really do take responsibility
themselves and that also shows
that as a veltheimer i
sit at the table more or less twice, on the side as a
customer and on the side as an entrepreneur
the wind farm can do the needs of a
woman on purpose  wrong 1000 households
jay mohr danny willett news that even
a present and
transport minister jean gray and at the
moment when one
also benefits a bit from this
not quite
ideal of beauty yes to put
it that way that the discussion as far as
disturbing influences are concerned
at least let it die down a bit
feldheim hannes the monument v  alley
state of former military errani if
interested in meet the needs of the
flies 600 aviary wood
in the village interceptor the producer
and power day one piece of the university this
falls the man has driven this woman
like it still
occupies many people today how heats up  in the
winter and are there other possibilities
so wrongly imagined biogas planned and
integrated power station in pieces from
waste watchers liquid man only 19 3 million
so remains with lausannes matt
winston 6004 song at the expense of an
almost endless
missions
in order to supply oliver feldheim
drive  energy company and produce at
plant in independence day the day job
how electrified develop completely
liter ton measure the special
feature here in veltheim is actually that the
people of veltheim have their own network so basically
buy electricity from the wind farm here and then directly in the house
consumers here in front  place are in easy
pack for national energy supply themselves
freshly inte  ntion is - on the local
supply it refused
the network for this village way available
points
simply didn't want to exist that even
this small Gallic village itself
create cattle
because we won't
let it get us down you know you're so ready that
either a hands  on invested
Friesenjungs internally more than 107 million
from the
lottery jackpot
there was actually no discussion
, so most of the time they were willing
to make this contribution
everyone is now more or less an entrepreneur who
can participate there and also have a
say in how we go with our network above how to
design because the prices  from local
utility company big load
often comes aggressive july may come first
phone charges bretthauer roger drives
home had to sony
playstation inc the comics on so
fisch energie cottbus is with smart
switch and new face of duty elite squad
so the biggest difference we
feel since he  moved in
really that was half must
stromko  sten have
[music]
10 residency probably for taking part
12,000 know that from all around the
world
but
politics like in Germany there are
different places with
different framework conditions there
are also groups from abroad
hunters come so that groups from Africa
the  we here to visitors are particularly
interested in the use of
photovoltaics partly also in self-sufficiency
and use the small remote
villages bring the use of electricity to the
region
the text part of the about noble energy
sources is now out of place because a
political experiment decides on the left
we had  yes, that it is actually
fortunate that politics here, in that case, the
state secretary in the ministry of economics
of the state of brandenburg said at the time
, okay, you now have a
solution, there is nothing that
really allows it and there is also
nothing that really prohibits it and i
say  makes but proves to me that it works
and the  colleague gave the thumbs
up and that led to management
who want to move something not
necessarily making it more difficult
digitizing the approval
process simplifying the approval process sometimes it takes
between four and up to
ten years to get approval for the wind farm, sometimes even longer
so we can  not creating the energy turnaround in the
short term and also not
expanding renewable energies so much
up to now is actually nice from
the government forever if
the government not only announces
the energy turnaround with
renewable energies but maybe
also thinks through to the end and says we use
such decentralized ones  things quite simply
said many small fields around
berlin could still supply berlin i
menowins nexans for eric
now costs complete
with josef f